so this is a collab i did with dr
anthony j
he wrote a book called astro generation
and
he's got a website and share the screen
because there's a few things here i want
to cover
boom boom boom okay
let's go here for a second so he wrote
this book called estrogeneration
uh the subtitle the book is why you're
sick
fat and infertile or something like that
or basically
the entire concept of the book is
there's these environmental estrogens
which
get into a man's body and makes them
weak
basically beta-ass [ __ ] and it's a big
problem it's
in my opinion one of the greatest
contributors to
the weakening of men today uh
is is this very book that we got from dr
anthony j breaking it all down for us
where's this thing here anyway so this
is the video over here
we had a huge long talk went through
everything oh we're gonna
damn commercials running on anyway watch
it later i've already dropped the link
for you i want you guys to watch later
so this is right off of his website
updated list of estrogenic substances
top 10 of the daily estrogenics from his
book ester generation
again read it for yourself if you really
want to get into it phytoestrogens
plant estrogens which main exposure
comes from
flax soy lavender and cannabis smoke
i did ask him about cannabis vaping when
i had him on for the interview and he
said
that's not estrogenic cannabis smoke so
if you're combusting
your herb it's estrogenic if you're
vaping it you're okay
but plant estrogens specifically
flax i used to put flaxseed oil
in my shakes because it's a healthy fat
not anymore i haven't done that since i
talked to dr anthony j
soy there's a lot of arguments out there
between people on
especially you know it's like the vegans
versus everybody else sort of thing it's
like
soy's not bad for you yes it is so
conclusively it is bad for men if you
if you want to argue with somebody go
read his book and then you send him a
letter and you argue with him
conclusively it's bad for men it is
estrogenic in the male body there is no
question about that
lavender lavender
is a wonderfully fragrant flower sounds
you know it smells great
but it's estrogenic there's a lot of
toiletry products
women use it a lot of the time in uh
like oils
um it's it's infusing the candles a lot
of the time so like the scent
um so you have to be careful with
lavender if your dude so those are the
main ones here
again read the book if you want to get
you know deep in the details but this is
like
you know the surface level stuff which
will be very very important
uh mycoestrogens uh so fungus
funguses can be uh estrogenic but the
main source
he concluded in the book came from
grains okay
so don't buy cheap ass shitty food
because
it could have one of the greatest
sources
of estrogenic compounds in the food
system comes from fast food
because they've got like they have to
have this system down it's a science we
have to move this [ __ ] out the door all
day long
and feed people for cheap and
unfortunately a byproduct of that
is a lot of it is estrogenic
atrazine is a herbicide uh it is very
estrogenic
um it's been used in um the u.s for a
long time
there's some states where it's banned
it's banned in canada
and throughout most of europe but if
you're an american you got to watch
where you're getting your food from
um atrazine is a very powerful herbicide
also they also put it in the [ __ ] where
you um
spray your weeds you know between your
stones and your bricks and all that
and it kills them it's very very
effective
but it's estrogenic in the human body so
you get it on your skin
you know you have kids playing around it
you're gonna have all kinds of problems
right so be careful with that kind of
[ __ ] with atrazine
uh i'm gonna butcher some of the
pronunciations of these
um try try colas whatever the hell
soap estrogen let's just move on to what
it is soap estrogens
um one of the big reasons why i've been
such a huge supporter of the tactical
soap
okay which is grondike soap company's
product is it's a handmade natural
pheromone soap
the ingredients what are the damn
ingredients side here it is
vegetable oil blend which is olive and
organic sustainable plant oils coconut
oil
and shea butter water sodium hydroxide
beer this is beer scented oh yeah this
is the beer one
orange oil androscendione
that's it nothing else just the
pheromones
now i challenge you to go grab your bar
of
i don't know what's a popular brand
irish spring or something
dove men's friendly whatever just grab
it
take a look at the side of it you're
going to see
all kinds of chemicals on there but
you're going to want to look for ones
that
sound like benzophene or anything with
fiend at the end of it hang on i gotta
put this back up on the screen sorry
let's make this a little bit bigger i
didn't realize i minimized that to show
okay let's slide this over here okay
that
should work for you anyway um so
anything that you see with
benzo fiend anything ending in fiend
anything ending in xyldene
these are the problems okay you're gonna
get these a lot um there's another one i
picked up some sunscreen the other day i
know we cover sunscreen so
i'll save that for that one next too but
you got to be careful with
toiletries cheap shampoos cheap
conditioners
uh skin gels fragrances um
you know the like even the expensive
ones you know you watch these fragrance
channels and these dudes are like oh you
gotta spray this on and it smells like
musk and raccoon and bear piss all mixed
together and you're gonna get ladies
throwing them so
it's all [ __ ] chemicals man and
they're mostly estrogenic
uh you don't need a 300 bottle of a
fragrance to get girls
trust me trust me okay
pay attention here man um
red number 40 is a artificial red food
coloring you'll find it in any of these
energy drinks that you see in the gas
stations
that are of a red color any food that
you see with red coloring
you see red cake you know like red
velvet cheesecake or some [ __ ] like that
that's got red number 40 in it
that's estrogenic in the male body
parabens which is the fragrance
estrogenic which i was talking about a
little bit earlier
all those cheap [ __ ] [ __ ] sprays that
you put on your body and you see guys
doing this stuff
and you know they have like a wall of
800 women coming at them and the dude's
doing this
that is estrogenic
marketers are great they're going to
sell you on this crap but it's
estrogenic you don't need any of that
crap
phthalates plastic additive estrogenic
so
any food or beverage packaged in plastic
is estrogenic you cannot even rely
on bpa
sorry it's saying bpa free because even
packaging that says bpa-free
might be bpa-free in the cap but the
bottle itself has bpa or vice versa
and even then when it's labeled bpa-free
don't trust it you should be drinking
fluids out of
like use a water uh container that's
refillable either glass or metal
but not plastic even if it says bpa-free
stay away from that [ __ ]
and ee-2 which is birth control
a lot of you guys don't know this but
they cannot filter
hormones from sewage water
there's a lot of women that are on birth
control and have been for a long time
they drink their fluids all day long
their coffees their teas and their
waters and they go to the bathroom they
have a
little whiz all of that urine that gets
into the
uh septic systems they they get out
particles they get out the crap the
toilet paper everything else you flush
down a toilet
but hormones cannot be removed
by the water filtration plants okay
so birth control ends up in the drinking
water if you're drinking tap water
that's unfiltered
you're estrogenic guarantee it
that's why you see so many dudes walking
around today with female breast tissue
there's actually men getting breast
cancer today
just think about that marinate on that
for a second all right
let's go down here i'm gonna rip through
this uh so we're not on this
too too long tonight this little uh
chart here i'm gonna grab this page
uh you guys can open up another window
and watch along if you want with it or
just
reference it for later uh so we covered
the top 10 estrogens which i just went
through
anyway you guys can take a look at all
this it's it's it's a really really
useful
uh website um the other one that i
didn't cover in here as well is
sunscreens
do not use anything with oxybenzone
uh basically anything that you see on
packaging that's got
benzone or zone on or something like
that it's it's
it's generally speaking probably going
to be estrogenic
right so you want to use zinc based
sunscreen only
sometimes they cost a little bit more
but hey if you give a [ __ ]
you're going to pay attention to that if
you're not have fun doesn't matter to me
you